someone needs explain how that knife
made that sound especially since it was
simply being used to carve a pumpkin I
admit it's how a serial killer would
carve a pumpkin but that sound isn't
coming from that knife for any reason
also forget Michael Myers it was this
crazed woman swinging this giant
butcher's knife around a group of
children but the rest of the movie takes
place in California so it seems a bit
dickish not to set the opening part of
the film and Haddonfield
this is Marian from the original
Halloween remember her yeah me neither
but considering her one character trait
is smoking cigarettes it's kind of
amazing she's not dead 20 years later I
kinda want to give nurse Mary an ass in
bat since she's actually acting smart by
walking away from the house instead of
into it but she's still gonna find a way
to get killed which means we have to
waste a few more minutes of screen time
until the inevitable so Kirk wrong
killer movie we all know the hockey mask
wearing villain comes from an entirely
different series called Friday the 13
Mutant Ninja Turtles also is that Joseph
gordon-levitt here's a sin Joseph
gordon-levitt hasn't anyone told you
secondhand smoke kills discount Andrew
Garfield four nine four six Cypress pond
I wouldn't marry and call the cops
herself is there some strict rule in her
neighbor's household to never let anyone
else use the phone even if they're
calling the cops
[Music]
one of the composers of this movie is
Marco Beltrami who did scream but the
problem with letting belt romney do any
of the score is that it sounds exactly
like screams music like he just gave
them all the unused compositions the
director said let's have your character
eat one bite of a halloween cookie it'll
make you look even more like joseph
gordon-levitt
I guess this automatic door thing didn't
stop with the first film so how did it
go from fairly bright outside to
darkness in like two minutes because if
you tell me it's symbolism I refuse to
learn anything the cops buy even my most
conservative estimate and even though it
went from day to night in no time there
was no way 15 minutes passed for her to
give up on the cop so soon obvious
publicity photo of Donald Pleasence on
the set of an earlier Halloween film
stupidly masquerading as a personal
photo of the character it's obvious and
stupid why would Loomis have a file on
Laurie Strode
she was never one of his patients and
considering to find out later she's
changed her name and been hiding out in
California for the last 20 years
how would Loomis even know where the she
was also even if Michael was able to
assume dr. Loomis had info on Laurie's
whereabouts how did he find out that he
could ransack Marian's house to find
those files Marion was a nobody in the
first film she drove the car that
Michael would steal but that's about it
also also what the as Michael Mayer has
been doing for the past 20 years since
these films are choosing to ignore parts
4 through 6 the last time we saw him he
was being burnt alive so he just ran
away on fire stopped dropped and rolled
and then what Jimmy like what even
compelled Michael to come over and kill
the neighbors let's review Michael broke
into Marian's house found a file on
Laurie Strode then camped out at the
neighbor's house he let them all live
while Jimmy called the cops waited some
more then killed the kids and came back
to Marion's house what the meanwhile
Michaels improved his standing dead
people up next to doors that he somehow
knows someone will open at just the
right time technique he needs to give
Jonathan Silberman and Andrew McCarthy a
call because they couldn't get that
right for two movies you know what movie
go yourself Mary Anne survived two
encounters with this maniac there should
be a slasher movie rule that if you
survive one film you get a pass for the
rest of the franchise those cops don't
hear a can car pulling out of the
driveway of the very house they're
looking at it's been his life tracking
down that Halloween guy Michael Myers
thanks random forensics guy you've
successfully updated us on the plot of
every Halloween movie except for part
three but bonus points if you can
somehow sneak that exposition in field
News also Haddonfield can apparently
support two newspapers as this one is
called
field times moody can preach the h20 all
day but the title screen and every bit
of advertising made this movie looked
like was called Halloween water wow this
is a movie newspaper article that
actually appears to be about the events
in the film let's go ahead and take away
one oh we know we're on to fetus
experimentation stats by the third
paragraph and the article next to it is
titled Midwest is drowning rain and has
nothing to do with h2o just like this
movie I met him 15 years ago
fake dr. Loomis narration is that a
fucking police sketch of the mask
introducing Josh Hartnett they wrote a
separate article about Judith's
headstone being stolen Jesus must have
been a slow news day it's not like there
was a mass killer who had hacked up some
teenagers the previous evening newspaper
articles somehow makes the mistake of
saying the Halloween murders were in
1968 and 1978 this movie is h2o not h3o
glad movie clues us in and so why we
should care about October 31st otherwise
I might have thought it was to mourn the
anniversary of Houdini's death or
celebrate Rushmore being completed
horror movie victim thinks she sees
previous stalker closes her eyes and
when she opens them he's not there
anymore cliche way little man Tate score
Jodi Lynn Michael Myers returning after
a 20-year hiatus might be the second
most unbelievable thing in this movie
someone might have taught him to drive
at the Institute but doesn't appear
anyone taught him how to change a flat
tire also this is all a setup for
Michael to steal a car I guess this was
the only way to do it I'll always have
been waiting in this desolate rest area
also this is the same car he drove from
Illinois when Michael buys gas does he
use self-service burn does he put on a
slutty Halloween outfit to get an
attendant to do it or does he kill the
whole gas station I thought to know hey
I must know also also Michael broke into
Marian's house and stole the stuff in
Laurie's folder so somewhere in all that
there was information where she
relocated after faking her own death
also times three what's the point of the
scene no one dies in it and there was no
reason for Michael's car to have to
break down
there's so much padding in this movie
they didn't add bullet seems like this
it would be 45 minutes tops man there is
so much inconsistency with the masks in
the series I can't even understand why
at some point it wasn't just retired
even if he didn't die in the fire surely
a rubber mask didn't make it and it
looks brand new
but they still had you come to this
gathering at last Janet Leigh plays
alongside her daughter in a movie that's
not the fog which doesn't count because
nobody saw that anyway - scream queens
together and they're related but hey I
see Adam Arkin in the scene is his dad -
good for Halloween h2o yeah probably
also everyone balloons the fact that
Donald Pleasence his great career had to
end
Halloween six but no one seems to
mention that this was sadly Janet
Leigh's last the at record release talk
about taking one for the family leading
to two tumultuous round melon yes it's
hard to believe but this is literally LL
Cool J's audition for deep blue sea
mistakenly included in h2o wait a minute
deep blue sea
h2o I'm beginning to notice a pattern
here yep that's it both movies suck we
paying the bills off ha instead of a
jump-scare which was the intent this is
more of a jump angry like instead of on
fright I was like ah kill all the
phonies and that can't be healthy no
your mom told me the next time I let you
loose I was gonna look the next time why
were you fired before it sounds like
it's happened more than once no one
would be able to hear Ronnie's
girlfriend with the phone nowhere near
anyone's ears Danna Halloween movies
there are other ways to show that it's
Halloween other than having kids
unrealistically trick-or-treating in the
middle of the day these are totally some
of the same kids she saw on the other
side of the street running past her now
clown girl here clown girl there
no I Adam Arkin come on I see more
people dressed up looking around during
the days of Halloween movies that I ever
do on actual Halloween night also does
no one go to school in this town it's
all that's going on in your head is
leaking out of me and I can't take it
anymore I would explain that haircut 20
years don't you think he would have
shown up by now yep looks like Lori is
as clueless about vehicles behind her as
she was 20 years prior psycho hey I can
name other Janet Lee movies too there's
a psycho and uh that one where she no I
mean definitely psycho then probably
something with Tony Curtis I'm guessing
and I'll think of it oh yeah the
Manchurian Candidate Touch of Evil and
Bye Bye Birdie whoo
since we know that Michael isn't on the
grounds yet this attempt to be scary
serves zero purpose fair enough
did John get the flowers those are
clearly store-bought and the only thing
they had time to get while in town was
the stolen booze twenty years have
passed and nothing's changed Michael
always finds a way to be noticed at
school by one of the main characters
from her seat in the back of the
classroom or any thoughts on that guy in
a creepy mask you just saw at the window
might be a good idea to bring that it up
was about Redemption it was his fate
Jesus even the exact same classroom talk
about faith that Laurie was talking
about in the original happens 20 years
later but in this parallel be better
served with the Josh Hartnett character
since that would tie into the family
dynamic she changed her mind about
yourself
but how exactly would he get away with
this his overprotective as Laurie is
she's not going to be at the busses to
see him off and crazily enough that's
exactly what happens we're just gonna
add a hundred sins here for the
jumpscares they're clearly the dumbest
jump-scare who's ever committed to film
Hey
it's Halloween I guess everyone's
entitled to one good scare
nice call back at all but Laurie should
immediately go buy lottery tickets
because she has a much better chance at
winning the jackpot than having that
exact same phrase said to her twice in
her lifetime after literally being
jump-scare I know it's not my place if I
could be maternal for a moment you know
this movie sucks all the balls but this
is truly a sweet moment between
real-life mother and daughter getting to
act together for the last time you had
me at miss tape you had me at miss tape
SCOR decides to pay homage to the psycho
theme music as if to torture us with a
much better film and buy a better film I
mean that totally unnecessary remake of
psycho that came out four months after
this movie also cool homage to psycho
and all but does this school not have a
parking lot Jesus how long did it take
these buses to get to the front gate it
was daylight when they left also
28 seconds of buses driving so earlier
today Michael stopped by the school
grounds to stare into classrooms and
then decided to drive all the way out
here to wait for the buses to drive by
like there are a million places he could
have hidden that didn't require driving
halfway to Gethsemane
I want to tantalize myself with your
sweet nectar deepest bluest my hat is
like a shark's fin she replied why is
Ronnie still there does he have to work
a 24-hour shift I might be checking with
my union rep to see if that's legal well
I don't know who this is better open up
the gate there is no way Michael could
have gotten out of the car and hid in
the time it took Ronnie to walk out of
the office to the gate I mean what does
Michael have mosquito feet or something
that would prevent his footsteps from
being heard there are all sorts of
leaves and all over this road either
Michael drove this the perfect amount of
time it took for the battery to go out
or he has a remote control for this 1924
Model T Ford or whatever the fuck it is
he stole the rest stop why doesn't
Michael kill Ronnie here he's got the
advantage and Michael doesn't know how
terrible Ronnie is at his job to his
knowledge Ronnie is the one guy on
campus with a gun so kill him already
also lucky for Michael that most of the
school went on that use city trip I mean
he's a badass but he would have had a
hard time taking out an entire school
look Michael was literally just staring
at the back of Ronnie's head when could
he have cut the phone lines assuming
they're not right outside that window of
the guard shack
Adam Arkin in this universe scream - the
movie exists which means the first
scream exists which means all the
references to the Halloween universe and
those two movies exist which means a
full collapse of these universes as we
know them you have got to be kidding me
with these fucking candles guys are you
telling me the school had this many
candles lying around or that they bought
this money that they thought they needed
this money I want to know who's behind
the candle cabal also can kids make corn
on the cob if he doesn't know how to
teenage right
my name's not KK she waits until they're
making out to spring this news on him
can will not swallow or spit out
whatever he's gnawing on before making
out because if that's some kind of
fetish it's weird that locked him up for
a long time but he got out he came after
me are you gonna tell him that you've
had no idea he was your brother until
Halloween - movie that apparently exists
in your universe since The Scream
franchise does what happened the sister
she died right well she faked her death
it's kind of strange that h2o ignores
Halloween four through six where Laurie
died in a car crash but takes that plot
point to create a soap opera plot twist
that she faked her death he sent a
sanitarium for 15 years waiting for me
and then one rainy night he decides to
go trick-or-treating wait a minute well
it's Michael trick-or-treating that
night but he was doing that all wrong
why does Michael care about
anniversaries and birthdays and the
first movie he waited 15 years to kill
people on Halloween and in this one he
waited 20 for some reason all because
his nephew turned 17 this anniversary
trigger is totally whacked I get that
this would be a bit scary to stick your
hand down a disposal but how does he
expect the switch to turn on by itself
it's as if he knows he's in a movie
called Halloween h2o and he's about to
be killed also after all this build-up
at the hand and the disposal with the
fact that he doesn't get his hand
chopped off is 100% a sin eating be part
of the sex games
how the fuck does Michael know when
people are going to discover the body he
sets this bit up perfect every time
character in movie full of nothing but
cheap scares criticizes a cheap scare
that his friends might be trying to pull
off could Steve miner just tell the
actors if they couldn't think of
anything else to do to pretend that they
were chewing on something god the eating
in this movie waste of time these last
couple of minutes have been what I know
the story is the story and whatever
happens happens but Sarah escape Michael
through the dumbwaiter shaft just two
minutes ago and is now being stabbed to
death this movie could have done just
about anything that was cooler with the
dumbwaiter but it chose inevitable
stabbing death instead
when did Michael cut the power the
garbage disposal was working just a
minute ago and there's a light on in the
room behind them how did Michael set up
this death reveal so quickly think about
that he has to do to make this work he
needs a stepladder and a conveniently
hanging light bulb wire to make that
happen not to mention that he knew for a
fact that there would be such a setup in
this pantry also thought the power was
out so how exactly does this work also
also what the fuck did he have against
Sarah charlie just got a slice of the
neck but she really got worked over I'm
guessing he's not cut biggest she's all
that whatever it takes fan Michael an
incredibly efficient killer stabs John's
leg instead of anywhere that might kill
him faster how and then cos John Ronny
he just got stabbed in the leg damn Maui
you wouldn't lasted one day on the creek
Michael fruitlessly stabs the air from
outside the gate I guess hoping that one
of these stupid kids will run towards
the knife and stab themselves man how
been great with the scene of been in a
good movie who I just told you about
earlier convenient right life of a final
girl and what can you do also I know
Laurie's older and accepts Michael Myers
being her brother but I sincerely doubt
she'd refer to him that way it's not
like they have any real familial
connection at all it's not like they
played trouble together when they were
kids
wouldn't she disown him in some way due
to you know the evil
all right he's we'll see now - because
that was clearly Michael and not Ronnie
so why the fuck would Ronnie be walking
into the school without yelling for help
or someone he knows I just walked in
here like a zombie it's no wonder the
wheel thought he was Michael Myers even
though he could have waited a few
seconds to confirm it also also did a
man Arkan even hit LL Cool J once during
this shooting he was especially good at
hitting the flower sconce but I don't
think one shot actually hit him maybe
Michael would also have a solid career
as a knife demonstrator he can make
butcher knives hold people up high in
the air with the greatest of ease this
is yet another car won't start in a
horror movie cliche that seems bigger
than the last one you probably remember
I want you to drive down the street
through the Becker's the mile down the
road hopefully Casey isn't too busy on
the phone when you get there how did he
keep his body either prostrate or
scrunched up and off to stay hidden
while Laurie walked through this hallway
mother must hit the gym three times a
day
also this seems to say that Michael knew
Laurie would come back after driving
away he saw the car drive off Shrugged
went back into the school jumped to the
ceiling and weight total goddamn bull I
can maybe understand Michael being able
to walk without anyone hearing him but
jumping on a goddamn table without
anyone hearing him flagpole Sitta yeah
he's totally dead Laurie good thinking
in the first movie Loomis shot him six
times said he fell out a window and he
burned to death in Halloween - so this
should take care of it and you shouldn't
worry at all you should totally disarm
yourself a little cool J like the
opposite of a deus ex machina looks like
a homonym who'd affect him which roughly
translates to a human also how is this
asshole still alive dude was in a pool
of his own blood even though we never
saw Adam Arkin hit him with one fucking
bullet the bullet just grazed me yeah
that's why I looked totally dead and
didn't wake up for 10 minutes of the
movie can graze cause that cue even if
I'm willing to overlook Michaels clear
sense of dramatic timing for his
resurrections I am not buying that he
can see through a goddamn body bag to
know when Laurie is looking at him come
on come on
what run the fuck over him multiple
times in fact just drive the van on top
of him and put it in park instead Laurie
waits for him to get up to do this for
some reason putting herself in danger by
trying to drive him off a cliff and
taking the van with it
Loree survives this acts on the ground
that was previously in the van is
conveniently waiting outside for Laurie
so that she doesn't have to get it from
the van that is now on fire come on you
a movie also is Michael seriously
playing the sympathy brother/sister card
here and even if he's smart enough to
think of that isn't he also smart enough
to know it won't work alright movie well
played and once in or in back also there
shouldn't be any more movies after this
bleep you see there's a Halloween
resurrection that came out four years
later and the stars Busta Rhymes it
stars Busta Rhymes this is one instance
where he should have stopped saying give
me some more also also man he's
seriously messed up if in the next film
Laurie isn't an insane asylum because
she actually killed a paramedic and not
her brother thank God that doesn't
happen no no water no liquids just call
me call call if you feel like you've
called too many times don't take drugs
[Music]
wait for the police these officers god
bless them they remind me of my days
when I had to run from the police a
marina it spigot II think I am what do
you think I am
human hey Ted where the hell's parks bro
hello if I can change and you can change